since we have a lot of european friends
so
starting next
semester in january we'll be in ph so
hopefully we'll see each other
so today i want to introduce the
connection where a lot of work have been
done between optimal transport and
universal problems just a very brief
overview of universe problem so usually
for pde people we are given initial
conditions under condition all the
coefficients necessary
a lot of effort in employment in several
decades has been like how can i solve
the problem how can i solve the pde
efficiency and it does belong to the
modeling step which i refer to as a
forward problem so we're given
everything we want to get the data and
the as accurate as possible well
numerous problems we are concerned with
the other way around we are given some
data maybe not exactly the solution or
some observables or some functionals of
the solution and we are interested in
what exactly the boundary condition
initial condition
coefficient that that caused me to tell
us that we can see that data and here is
a lot of um
interesting numerous problems in our
daily life including
california east very southern part how
to locate earthquake source and also
like how can i detect artifact artifact
a material before breaking it and also
medical imaging like accuracy et cetera
they all belong to the fact that
we want we have data and we want to
refer the parameters
but if we take it to a general framework
i think a lot of the learning our
machine learning problems in a general
uh category also belong to the universe
problem or universe state uh data
fitting problem the fact that we have a
model and the model can be pde can be
ode can be any model like neural network
is one of them and we have a lot of data
that information tells us and we want to
learn the coefficients and the sum of
the coefficients are the weights or they
are just like a physical coefficient in
my pe so a lot of the problems that we
are interested in belong to this
framework and usually they are very
large scale and they are very non-linear
so in order to find the coefficients the
final way that we turn to is
optimization and unfortunately most of
the time they are non-combat
optimization and a large scale as well
because it's large scale and the
non-complex
the problem to solve them become like
gradient-based methods
so uh there's a lot of places that you
see optimal transport will actually
distance in this entire bigger framework
so for example we can change the
objective function in the non-convex
optimization using russian distance or
we can change the matrix
space where i assume my parameter
leaving so for example i can assume it's
living in various space then i have
actually language flow and i have a
different gradient distance formula
or i can study the convergence of the
parameter in the washer stem
framework so that's about convergence
and also finally if i think it's the
whole thing is the empirical measure
then i can study the mean field limit
what if i have my discrimination and
going to infinity then that's another
framework that people study
so in my
research in the past eight years has
been as the objective function for
washington d and try to understand what
does it mean to use russian design what
can i gain by doing so
so again back to this uh constraint
optimization problem usually comes from
the a particular model f of m and here
i'm making very general it can be a
neural network where it can be od or pde
so what is the number of us in terms of
practitioners is that one gradient is
zero and the training stops and i'm at a
very big loss so that's like a very
difficulty in training in um in machine
learning people will in turn uh
interpret it as oh i didn't train well
but in physical part we will say we
didn't reconstruct the parameters so
usually this is a nanometer and so this
is why we bring inversions and distance
to tackle so gradient is zero at the
places that is now global minimum
usually because
our gradient dj dm is zero not because
dj df is zero usually when we choose the
objective function we choose it as a
convex function like l2 norm it's
convexing s
so dj df will not be zero unless we are
really at the truth well the fdm is
really about our model so usually when
we choose a good model and that model is
already good enough if the fdm is zero
then there's no uniqueness then the
problem is kind of hopeless so if we
have this assumption that the model is
good and we choose a complex function of
the data and we still observe that
gradient zero usually because orthogonal
projection
right when these two are projecting
together as my constraint gradient and
the depth is zero so that's why
introducing for example a different
objective function will help us because
if my djdf can be aligned with the fdm a
little bit better
then i won't encounter so many places
that give me zero gradient and it
doesn't need us to understand what is
the model and also to other understand
what is the fdm which what i call
continuous dependence between your data
and your parameters
so that's where we see
i just want to give you an example where
in this particular hyperbolic equation
based the universe problem well the data
is wave my parameter is the velocity so
the continued dependence is the
transport type of feature
so if we use like euclidean norm like l2
norm while there's millions places i
will have a orthogonal projection and my
gradient will get stuck but if i use the
vascular distance as my objective
function the transport feature is
aligned with the models feature so we
can eventually reduce the residual to
almost nothing and have a very very very
uh well uh
planetary construction
okay so the question is what type of
problem will be nice if i couple it with
rashes and distance okay then that's
where we need to dig into to see if this
problem has geometric information yet
and apart from hyperbolic equation we
can still have a few very
tiny examples like
uh inversion and transport flow or
projection or some deconvolution with
localized sources etc but i think
we will see more examples in this case
and another interesting property of
using the vessels and distance in
optimization is the better stability and
this is related to a lot of theoretical
understanding about the connection
between values and distance correlative
vectors and distance and
h minus one seminar since we are in the
h minus one seminar they belong to the
weaker side of l2 if we pick r2 in the
middle h1 belong to strong side h minus
one belongs to v cross side and a weaker
norm by definition
has a coefficient of so basically you
can see all the h as the basement norm
has divided l2 while waiting is on
different frequency coefficient
so this could see if s is negative one
it means i have a lot of weight on the
lower frequency and very little weight
on the higher frequency so we focus a
lot on the low friction component and
that's why it's so
stable with respect to high frequency
noise and the connection that rashes and
distance is related to this type of
weaker norm also in its kind of reason
why we observe this phenomenon
where my data is quite noisy visually by
eyeball misfit or by auto misfit but as
the iteration continues i can still
reconstruct what the true mammoth model
should be and this is also tightly
connected to the geometric feature of
vectors and distance because when we
compare these two signals the black and
the blue one we just our measures and
this are not just point wisely compared
so we always move and because it's dense
so when you move you can the
amplitude can be a lot better you really
move a little that's why in total the
rashes and distance between the black
and the blue is extremely small under
that's why we don't see the noise and
that's where the stability kicks it
okay finally for conclusion so this is
the most two benefits uh that i have
uh experienced with rashes and decent as
the objective function one is if you are
dealing with geometric um type of
inverse problem the matrix and distance
along much better with the continuous
dependence so you observe a better
convexity and then the second part is
stability and that's related to the h
minus one one well i think uh there's
actually a general wp versus w minus one
t in the soviet space
and there's a several works that have
several particular universe format we
have tried like conversion rate from
inversion parameter identification for
dynamical system and some image
processing but the fact that
the metric can give you some implicit
regularization so all the examples here
didn't have any regularization it's just
the objective on itself but we are
stable with noise that's because there's
a implicit localization and it's not
just limited to objective function it
can be also the likelihood function in
our basic inverse it can also be the
residual such that when you solve a pde
you can solve it faster so in the end uh
i like to quote my friend's pitch
diseases figure that if we are dealing
with the universe problem we care about
all the
components coerced and the fun feature
the best
method will be a combination of all the
metrics you know not my metric and so
often
so that's the end of my presentation
thank you very much
[Applause]
any questions
i have a question so why don't you
optimize directly uh let's say the h
minus one norm or just even do a low
pass filter and optimize straight up on
the uh
your fourier coefficient your load
is it because it's just not convenient
uh no it's actually a very very good
method the industry standard in solving
applications
uh basic inversion they always go from
the smooth data where they do filtering
it's very common but the question is the
geodesic in the resources and design is
still very unique it's really just go
the transport direction well we use h
minus one h minus ten norm there's still
a local feature in it
and another thing is the uh i want to
mention there is actually a part that
this versus a distance this okay
is a weighted h minus one norm and the
deviated actually get give us a lot of
flexibility
because that is changing with the data
and that's also there's non-linearity
comes in
an example from
imaging where you can profit from using
the same distance
ah that's actually a good question i
didn't observe that yet so the work that
i mentioned was actually using the
general age as norm
all right
i think kerala has a lot of work in that
well there's one paper i guess which
knowledge
all right so let's thank you again